this is the context of constant concern
if you're a South Korean politician
missile launches from North Korea there
have been more this year than at any
time for over a decade
the fear is that this man Kim Jong-un is
planning more a full-scale nuclear
weapons test at a time where things are
as tense as they've been for years
but North Korea has I believe some other
intentions handok Sue is the prime
minister of South Korea he spoke
exclusively to Sky News and said it is
now expected We Gather that they are
ready to do something our allies and
partners are
totally on a lot although we do not know
exactly when but we gather that they are
prepared North Korea says it's
responding to joint military drills
between America and South Korea but
rhetoric has ramped up South Korea has a
new president who promised a more
hawkish approach president Yoon actually
ran on a platform where he said he would
be harder on North Korea and do you not
think to a degree that has in itself
escalated tensions you may call our
strengthening our deterrence
capabilities the harder line I'm fully
prepared to accept that we will secure
our is on our terms not not on terms
dictated by North Korea there appeared
to be until two on Kim jong-un's
daughter she's appeared with him at
recent missile launches a rare glimpse
into the most secretive of families and
a hint perhaps about the succession the
launching of
InterContinental
is a big thing for North Korea
possibly the appearance with his
daughter for him he would like to
deliver us a message
the world is to an extent holding its
breath to see what this isolated leader
will do next hopes of a de-escalation
feel faint Helena Smith Sky News in
Beijing